[Music]
Disney Princesses are the most beautiful
kind and sweet women we know but it is
hard to believe that they didn't even
try to be a little wild when they were
teenagers this is why three artists
reimagined what they would look like in
the modern world make sure you watch
this video until the end to see what
Pocahontas has been up to if you love
Disney Princesses as much as we do don't
forget to subscribe and please give this
video a big thumbs up today we're
showing you ten Disney Princesses
reimagined as modern-day bad girls Ariel
The Little Mermaid has always been a
little rebel when she lived under the
sea she used to be fascinated by the
world of humans she collected things
that used to belong to them and loved to
visit a shipwreck with her friend
flounder Ariel even dared to go to the
surface of the ocean to meet her friends
scuttle a seagull who didn't really know
the human culture but Ariel had to keep
that passion secret from the other
mermaids in the kingdom of Atlantica her
father King Triton had said previously
that the contact between mer people and
humans was forbidden that didn't keep
the Little Mermaid from realizing her
dreams and becoming a human to meet the
love of her life her father would
probably never approve that she
exchanged her voice for legs but Ariel
did it anyway she's the kind of girl who
doesn't listen to anyone when she knows
what she wants and it seems like now
that she's a full-time human Ariel found
another passion as NAT a street art
reimagined her she now wants to be part
of a new world a world of basketball
players and think she will know
everything about them by playing this
video game
she looks so cool that we think these
athletes won't mind talking to her but
if she wants to be part of their world
she will have to prove that she can
really use her new pair of legs
Belle this young lady was such a nice
and smart girl that we would never see
her breaking the rules yes she was a
little bit strange but in the best way
villagers were surprised to see a young
woman reading books when most people
didn't even know the alphabet at that
time but Belle didn't even care because
she thought that fiction was more
interesting than reality however there
is one time she didn't listen to her
father and this is the only time he
wished she did when maurice was thrown
behind bars Belle decided to rescue him
she finally found him in beasts castle
and asked if she could take his place
her father absolutely didn't want her to
do
but she forced him to accept and this is
how the young woman was trapped in the
castle of the monster everyone was happy
in the end and battle even chose to stay
in the castle with her prince but what
if she had really been a bad girl
instead of being a hero when you see how
not a street art reimagined her you know
that it is impossible for anyone to
think that this girl is strange
she is cooler than ever maybe this is
what happens when you marry a handsome
rich man in the 21st century tiana this
young lady didn't have time to break the
rules in any way since she was a child
she dreamed of opening a restaurant with
her father and when he passed away it
wasn't time for her to do all the things
she ever wanted to do instead she wanted
to make him proud and work hard to start
her own business this is why instead of
partying Tiana was working as a waitress
in a restaurant she barely had time to
fully enjoy life but she thought that
she would be doing this later then one
day a frog offered her all the money she
needed to make her dream come true Tiana
finally accepted to kiss that random boy
and she immediately regretted it
that crazy adventure ended up being one
of the best things that ever happened in
her life but we think that what she
likes most is having the chance to work
hard again in her restaurant however if
the princess doesn't have time to act
like a bad girl she at least has time to
look like a bad girl as she was
reimagined on Disney hardcore with her
black dress her cool piercings and all
the tattoos she doesn't look like a
princess like any other with naveen's
playful personality we think that they
will make the perfect couple
Elsa the princess had always been
different but she thought that it was a
bad thing Elsa was embracing her powers
as a kid but after hurting her little
sister she thought that it was better to
stay away from others this is why
instead of being true to who she is she
decided to lock herself in her room Anna
was probably the most disappointed to
have lost her sister during all these
years but all kids have to rebel at some
point in their lives and Elsa did it a
little too late after being crowned
Queen her sister made her a little angry
and this is when she revealed her power
to everyone not able to face this
situation Elsa simply ran away leaving
her responsibilities behind and giving
herself the chance to do whatever she
wants Elsa finally came back to
arendelle to save everyone but
everything would have been way less
complicated if it happened during her
teenage years when her parents were
to help her but what would she look like
at that time if she had the chance to do
anything she wants when you see how this
artist reimagined her on Disney hard
core you can easily understand that Elsa
needed to let go of a lot of things she
doesn't look like a nice girl anymore
and we love to see that she finally
dares to be herself Jasmine she was
probably one of the luckiest princesses
on our list but that doesn't mean that
she was happy Jasmine had everything she
ever wanted in her palace except one
thing freedom and it just became worse
when she understood that she would soon
be forced to marry someone even if she
hadn't found the love of her life yet
this is why she decided to leave
everything behind and escape her palace
it wasn't the best decision as she
didn't know anything about the outside
world but she was lucky to be saved by
Aladdin who always does his best to help
the people in need and he also gave her
what she needed the most the freedom to
fly away on a magic carpet and discover
a whole new world
Jasmine finally broke the rules a little
to marry a thief and this is how they
lived happily ever after
but what if Jasmine decided to be a bad
girl even though she has to stay in the
palace here's how not a street art
reimagined her her father probably isn't
happy to see that his daughter is
smoking and wearing a really provocative
outfit but at least she's at home and
that's all that matters
will Aladdin be even more intimidated by
her new look only the future will tell
what will happen between these two Snow
White as the youngest Disney Princess
Snow White was barely a teenager when
her life changed forever she could have
been a spoiled kid being born in a royal
family when her parents passed away her
evil stepmother decided that this child
shouldn't be so lucky after all this is
why she decided to dress her in rags and
force her to work as a servant cleaning
the floors and washing the dishes
everyday the best thing she could ever
do was dreaming but things changed when
the Evil Queen decided to get rid of her
and Snow White had to run away in the
forest while she lived with the Seven
Dwarfs the only rule she ever broke was
trusting a stranger who gave her an
apple and it ended up being one of the
worst mistakes she ever made because she
passed away before being saved by a
prince but what if she were a little
luckier when she decided to be a bad
girl let's take a look at how not a
street artery imagined her Snow White is
still the fairest of them all but this
time she clearly knows it this is why
she keeps taking selfies in her bedroom
we think that her parents might still be
alive in the modern world because we
can't imagine her stepmother giving her
an iPhone even though she will probably
give her another Apple product a
poisoned one Cinderella when you work as
a servant you don't have a lot of time
to rebel that didn't keep Cinderella
from trying to go to the ball her
friends the mice made her a dress and
she was ready to party
unfortunately her evil stepsisters and
stepmother quickly made sure that she
couldn't even be dreaming anymore her
fairy godmother saw that it was unfair
and this is why she decided to give the
young woman everything she needed to go
to the ball and meet the love of her
life Cinderella was a teenager like any
other after all she ran away from her
home without asking her mother's
permission and decided to party all
night with a boy however there is one
rule that shouldn't be broken and it's
not just coming back home after midnight
it's talking to strangers if they had
known each other's names they wouldn't
be strangers anymore and it would have
been way easier to find each other but
with Prince Charming recognized
Cinderella with her new look as
reimagined by a she monster with her
pink hair piercing and choker necklace
she finally has the chance to look like
the bad girl she always wanted to be
it's no surprise that the Prince had to
make her try on a shoe to see if it fits
the size of her foot is the only thing
that didn't change Rapunzel trapped in a
tower for almost 18 years it's no
surprise that Rapunzel would like to
become a bad girl but during all her
teenage years she had always been
mommy's little girl
Rapunzel woke up at 7 a.m. to clean her
room she loved reading and she always
baked some cookies that's the kind of
daughter that most parents want but most
importantly she never cut her long
blonde hair to make sure that her mother
could use its magic power to stay young
forever we can't blame the princess for
being too nice and always obeying her
rules the only reason why she didn't
escape was that her mother lied to her
about the outside world but as soon as
she got a chance to be free and jumped
out of the window she never looked back
being a bad girl was the best thing to
do after all now let's see what Rapunzel
would look like if she was not a nice
girl anymore as reimagined on Disney
hardcore instead of painting her walls
her body is covered with tattoos she
also died her hair white which probably
took days and was really expensive we
bet that this modern-day Rapunzel still
lives with her parents because Mother
Gothel would never let her do that to
her magical hair Pocahontas
this young Native American was lucky to
have all the freedom that she wanted
when she was a teenager at any time of
the day she could just walk away into
the forest and discover the beauty of
nature with her friends Miko and flipped
unfortunately growing up means more
responsibilities and Pocahontas feared
to have to marry kocoum a brave warrior
who was too serious for her
free-spirited personality it's also at
that time that the English came to
America and the young woman couldn't
keep herself from breaking the rules
curious to learn more about the world of
these white men she met John Smith and
they quickly became friends this
relationship is what saved everyone at
the end but the two lovers were finally
separated and it it's better this way so
we have seen a young Pocahontas who grew
up in nature but what if she was born at
the beginning of the 21st century we
don't recognize this Native American
girl anymore now that we see how not a
street art reimagined her she is living
in a big city and loves Starbucks and
macaron and when it comes to exploring
the world all she needs is to turn to
her computer we bet that Pocahontas is
talking to cute boys all around the
world online it's always great to
discover different cultures Moana this
young woman always wanted to break the
rules since she was a child she was
fascinated by the sea but unfortunately
her parents wouldn't let her go anywhere
near water
that didn't stop Moana from one day
going on a big adventure
it wasn't easy the first time and we
thought that we would never see her on a
boat again
but Moana didn't give up she found out
that she was the chosen one and knew
that she was the only one who could save
her tribe it wasn't only about reuniting
a mystical relic with a goddess but also
finding out who she truly was Moana
almost gave up begging the ocean to take
the heart and choose someone else but
she finally understood that there was a
reason why she was chosen and she was
finally the one who saved everyone with
the help of demigod Maui being a
teenager is another big challenge and
some young women faced it by being a bad
girl that's the case for this modern day
Moana as not a street art reimagined her
this time her parents won't stop her
from going to the beach but from wearing
something that might be a little too
mature for her age if you could choose
one princess who could be a part of a
remake in the 21st century who would it
be don't be shy to tell us what you
think in the comment section down below
and that's it for 10 disney princesses
reimagined as modern-day bad girls
for more stories like this make sure you
watch ten Disney movies reimagined in
the modern day thanks for watching
[Music]